foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
concept commercialization Thermo
Fisher's unique approach to rapidly
advancing your antibody and protein
Therapeutics
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual genetics virtual week
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about Thermo Fisher
Scientific go to thermofisher.com
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find the live chat located at the right
of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to participate in three
poll questions in the middle of the
speaker's presentation
click on your answer when the poll
questions are displayed
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
I now present today's speakers
Steve Lewis senior product manager Gene
synthesis and synthetic biology Thermo
Fisher Scientific
and Jeff Howe PhD director scientific
and Technical Affairs Pharma Services
Thermo Fisher Scientific
or a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Steve and Jeff you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you Maria I really
appreciate you hosting us for today uh I
will be doing the first half of the
presentation and I'm very excited to be
here for today first I'd like to talk a
little bit just about Therma Fisher in
general uh we are of course a very large
organization but hopefully today through
this webinar we'll we'll help with
navigating it and I really seeing how
small and integrated our company truly
is we take a lot of Pride holistically
across the company in our in our mission
to enable our customers to make the
world healthier cleaner and safer
and today for our presentation we're
going to move into talking about the
agenda uh the first half will be
primarily about
um Services provided within Thermo
Fisher Scientific for uh early stage
Discovery in particular antibodies and
we will talk about why starting with the
gene or Gene synthesis is the fastest
way to move ultimately into the clinic
from r d into commercial scale
production so with the agenda here we're
going to start really at the beginning
of the therapeutic journey and
partnering with us we're going to talk
about optimization of your Gene as well
as very Advanced Next Generation Gene
synthesis as well as advanced protein
expression techniques and then also how
you move from going from selecting your
candidates from r d or in the r d
environment to ultimately reproduction
from there my partner Jeff will be
speaking about strategies for
accelerating your timeline to Clinic
mitigating risk as well as building a
foundation for success and how to get
started with Thermo Fisher right after
this presentation
so to provide a little bit of context
Thermo Fisher Scientific has been
working in the infectious diseases World
for for quite a long time and we wanted
to start here in terms of providing
context for uh today's presentation
because we have a long history working
within uh infectious disease starting in
2000 we had a very early
infectious disease response effort that
we worked on in terms of HIV all the way
through the mid-2000s and all the way to
today and of course you can read the
whole timeline and if you're watching
this as a recorded presentation you can
pause it and take a look at all of the
different details that we've been
working on for more than 20 years in
this space but I'd like to highlight
2020 and 2021 where we really did have
an impact a significant impact
partnering with many companies around
the world in terms of our response to
SARS cov2 the this is a very rapid and
very serious and very interesting time
not not just for us in the biotech space
but really globally and it was very
challenging and also rewarding to work
on a lot of these early stage activities
in terms of pandemic response and so if
you have any questions about some of our
activities in that space or how we
contributed to
the development of some of the vaccines
and Therapeutics as an organization we'd
be happy to talk about that we also have
some materials that we'd be happy to
send after this presentation to explain
a bit more in depth related to how we've
worked toward developing critical
vaccines at an unprecedented velocities
so for today
we're going to start really talking
about the early steps of Therapeutics
and vaccine development starting with
the early stage Discovery and research
through development clinical trials and
then ultimately commercial scale
production as I mentioned earlier Thermo
Fisher of course is a large organization
but today our Focus for our webinar is
really to show how you can go from idea
all the way through commercial
production in a relatively seamless way
working with our with our groups in the
work in Thermo Fisher Scientific
and for the first part of today we are
going to focus on uh the early Discovery
and research aspect as well as
development before moving into uh the
clinical trials aspect as well as
commercial uh production with our
partner Jeff
so today starting in the early Discovery
and research we really focus on the idea
of using recombinant DNA based just on
sequence information at the very
beginning to optimize your protein
production within our production
organization we do have the ability to
rapidly create DNA from a de novo Gene
synthesis processes but believe it or
not we actually start uh in a digital
way we start with a proprietary
algorithm that really helps us to
optimize the gene expression
uh or the protein expression resulting
from your Gene synthesis and so I'll
talk about some of those services today
but in particular I'd like to start by
talking about the discovery workflow
well you're seeing on the screen is what
we believe to be a very reasonable
timeline for starting at the r d scale
or producing what we refer to as
research use only uh targets for protein
production
and so we start on the left at the
project design level where we really
begin with just the electronic sequence
design
going through optimizing the the gene
ultimately to result in higher yields of
protein production
and then we can actually do the DNA
synthesis as part of that and we will do
the prototyping in-house and send you
your uh Gene of desire and if you'd like
we can actually take it all the way
through uh subcloning plasmid production
as well as proteins and at any step
along the way at any any point in this
timeline you really do have the ability
to choose what's relevant to your
organization and your needs at a given
time you don't need to go through the
entire process to work with with our
group you can truly pick which aspects
of this Continuum that are most relevant
for you at the time of project design
and so for us today the mo the items
that are highlighted in red Gene
optimization Gene synthesis and proteins
are the ones that we're going to be
focusing on uh to in particular talk
about how you can move from r d to
production in the fastest way possible
first just for a little bit of context
you have uh in the protein expression
space very popular host systems that are
used for expression and so you can do
cell free expression which does not have
any uh kind of living components as
associated with it you can do bacterial
expression uh through E coli you can do
yeast expression insect expression or
mammalian expression and we'll talk
about primarily the complex proteins
that you can make via mammalian
expression and we will talk about how we
view that within our organization
to ultimately provide you with the
highest quality Gene that proteins
developed from genes in the fastest
amount of time
so as I mentioned starting out with the
mammalian cell lines that are typically
used for protein expression particularly
in therapy Therapeutics development you
have two that are the most common here
the hex 293 or the human embryonic
kidney cells and chose cells the Chinese
hamster ovary cells and the benefits of
mammalian cell lines is that you have
the ability to really
do post-translational modifications as
it compares to using another type of
expression system and that's really
important when you're thinking about
developing uh proteins like monoclonal
antibodies or
um bi-specific or tri-specific uh
applications because uh the reality is
the mammalian cell lines are the way to
go in terms of getting the highest yield
in the fastest amount of time at the
highest quality and different cells
whether it's the hex 293 or Cho cells uh
have different uses at different times
and we have that flexibility within our
organization to be able to one not only
offer both but two as an outsourced
service we will also make
recommendations about which ones to go
through for that optimal protein
expression
and so uh in terms of transfection
strategies uh we have a couple of
options that that you can use here
within our Gene art services and Gene
art is the name of our organization who
really focuses on that r d range of
protein expression from Gene to protein
and so
our our approach to it from a strategic
perspective is to have transient
expression for four to fourteen days
um which is how long it can ultimately
take depending on the sequence that you
are trying to uh design and then
ultimately Express you go through a high
efficiency transfection as part of the
process uh through expression and then
ultimately protein production uh so
that's very fast right and we're trying
to talk about the difference here
between what is transient expression
compared to what is stable expression
stable expression really takes uh months
in a lot of cases you're trying to get a
stable cell line at the end of your
process so that you can ultimately in a
reproducible and scalable way uh make
the protein that you're trying to make
as as your Target on various scales and
timelines at different times of of the
project that you have in mind so to kind
of summarize the way that I like to
think about transient expression versus
stable expression is that transient
expression is really when you have a lot
of squishiness or a lot of uncertainty
around kind of what your Gene sequence
is and how it's going to express when it
gets into a host cell system and then uh
after that
if you find a candidate that's kind of
working or you find a sequence uh and
ultimately clone and then plasmid that
works for you and works at various
scales because at Gene art we can scale
up from 24 well plates all the way up to
25 liter production scales at the higher
end you really do start to get a greater
sense of okay here's what stable cell
lime development would look like and
that can take months and this really
truly isn't comparing the two it really
is that transient expression in a way
from our perspective precedes that
stable cell line development and the
fastest way to do it when working with
our group Gene art Services is to go
through our Outsource transient
expression workflow which can be as
quick as four days or as long as 14 days
depending on the sequence and the
approach to actually doing the
expression so so to kind of summarize at
the very beginning Gene art will be
there for most of the uncertainty that's
that's where we specialize is when you
don't know what's going to happen call
genar that that is definitely where we
excel in that transient protein
expression space
now
uh focusing on the Discovery workflow
here we're going to start at the very
beginning right going from Project
design through Gene optimization and
then ultimately to proteins at the very
end of the process but let's start right
at the very beginning
when you are starting off we at Gene art
will ask you to send us a sequence
associated with what you are trying to
ultimately Express we have a proprietary
patented algorithm known as Gene
Optimizer it's our technology that
really takes into account many
parameters to optimize the mammalian
coding region and this allows us to
optimize
expression to hat result in the highest
yields that you can you can get right
now today we're very excited about this
uh
unique process that we have to
optimizing Gene sequences and when
coupled with our production processes
we've seen very strong increases in
terms of yield resulting from the
expression that that we do
following the optimization
and to talk a bit about uh really just
our world-class performance in this
regard we have a couple of studies that
have been published um and we can get
access to them and you can actually just
look them up as well they're they're
available but if you need a link feel
free to reach out to your Thermo Fisher
partner to be able to uh receive a copy
We have basically compared within this
study uh kinase protein expression and
our Gene Optimizer software consistently
provided higher expression levels
compared to the wild type Gene as high
as 200 percent and as low as 25
expression we have a very high
reliability with this algorithm it's
very unique we have some really talented
folks within our r d organization who
worked very very hard at the molecular
level to really understand what makes
sense when you're building an algorithm
to optimize that protein expression so
for those uh those proteins that were
tested in this study the technology did
provide the the best results out of
uh no other optimization algorithm and
that's what you can see in the one two
three four five in in each of the
studies uh showed consistent results
um and you can see in the paper here the
genart sections uh just exactly how much
the expression the optimization how much
of an impact the optimization actually
had and it truly does outperform all
other algorithms on the market today
this is uh selected uh slide from
another study that we that we posted as
well or we published as well
um where we looked at different protein
expression types so the last one we
focused primarily on kinase proteins but
this really is a study that was done uh
very in-depth to demonstrate that
different types of proteins also benefit
from being optimized through the gene
Optimizer uh whether it's transcription
factors to ribosomal proteins the
membrane proteins the cytokines you can
see the amount of increase that the
optimized Gene resulted in compared to
the wild type uh and it's it's pretty
impressive
um even in situations when you are let's
say not with the wild type getting any
expression at all if you look at the
bottom one the cytokines in that
particular case the the il-2 only
expressed in the event of the
optimization in terms of relative
expression and and that's just a
testament to how powerful the gene
Optimizer algorithm truly is uh within
the gene art environment and then as I
mentioned when it's coupled with our
production processes you're truly
getting the highest chance of the best
yield that you can get at the highest
quality as well
I'd like to move into talking about the
synthesis and expression uh part of our
presentation again staying within the
the gene Gene art family within Thermo
Fisher Scientific we're moving on to
really that next step the actual
synthesis itself now that that your
genes have been optimized
so we perform really Next Generation
Gene synthesis with within our Thermo
Fisher Scientific genar group we of
course as we mentioned started out with
Gene optimization through basically
bioinformatics and uh what today would
be considered machine learning processes
you move into a Lego synthesis
then Gene assembly then cloning
sequencing and final documentation
uh everything I just went over really
truly is a sequential process and the
process that we follow within our group
to make sure that you're ending up with
not just ex a cloned Gene but we're
really verifying it we're making sure
that uh you are getting increased
reliability even with a shorter
turnaround time that that route that
we're able to achieve through our
processes
um we are able to do very high
throughput that's that's something
that's fairly uh impressive at least
from my perspective in in terms of our
production Partners uh at our
manufacturing site they're very fast
they've been doing this for 20 years and
uh we have a really excellent team who
not only takes the time to do the
production but will also work to the
point that they can troubleshoot things
that we do protein production all day
every day and that's the unique thing
about this team they're very very
experienced and they are able to really
go from that optimized algorithm to the
express Gene and then uh Eric excuse me
to the to the gene synthesis and then
the Clone Gene and making sure that if
there are any troubles along the way
that we will do our due diligence to
make sure that you are getting the
highest sequence accuracy uh possible
and so all of these things combine doing
all of that in-house especially starting
with the gene synthesis itself
um it really allows you to go okay
ultimately at the end of my project I'm
trying to get an Express uh Express
protein antibody whatever it is and you
start to wonder okay well how can I
increase my chances for the highest
yield possible and that's what we mean
by Next Generation Gene synthesis from
our perspective is really starting at
the electronic level or the the digital
from a digital perspective where you
optimize the sequence before even
starting with any of the biology and
then after that Gene synthesis you have
the ability to move into bioproduction
with a bit more confidence
and so
after the gene synthesis uh you can
really move into an expression plasmid
and then do actual protein expression as
well you can see in the box that is uh
has a square around it right now these
are really the next steps in that
process on our way toward protein
production uh you will go from that
clone Gene to an expression plasmid
before ultimately doing the expression
as we mentioned before uh we really
championed that Gene Optimizer algorithm
to increase your protein yield from your
expression plasmid uh
we have a lot of design flexibility in
how you want to do your plasmid
preparation which is very high quality
and we do it all in-house and that's the
great thing about working with the with
the gene art group within Thermo Fisher
Scientific is because you're starting
your journey with the same group all the
way up to getting that protein
expression step done along the way you
can have full control over how your
process is going so starting from the
sequence like I had already mentioned
all the way through at this point the
expression plasmid or the positive
preparation gives you that ability to
have uniquely full control as opposed to
if you were to send in your clone genes
to uh another provider which you may not
have control over the different steps of
the process one unique thing about the
gene art group is because we do all of
these Services in-house for our partners
the that provides the unique ability to
control the different aspects of the
process as you progress through it
and then moving into expression uh we do
have a number of flexible expression
scales as I mentioned you can go as
small as 96 well plates
um for some of our more high throughput
or small scale protein expression uh
Services a lot of our partners will
start in the 100 to 300 milliliter range
in terms of their uh expression after
after the transfection
and as I mentioned when you're looking
toward therapeutic and ultim and vaccine
Development A lot of the time we're
going to be recommending or you're going
to be at it coming to us with those
mammalian expression systems which in
this case uh we really prefer the xb293
and XP chill but we will also
also uh insect Expressions there are
certain proteins that do Express better
within those sf9 uh insect cells and so
that's something just to be aware of
that we offer it but truly where we
Excel is in that transient protein
expression of those mammalian expression
systems
for the right part of the slide I'll let
you read it I'm going to get into more
detail here in a second but our approach
overall uh if you look at the bottom the
bottom line there our approach to
bioproduction is really collaborative we
want to be a strategic partner for you
we have a project management team who
will help you with getting up to speed
our local manufacturing team is also
collated co-located with some of our
project management team and some of our
sales support and customer support staff
and so that benefit of doing all of it
in-house with Gene art is one great way
that you can really drive that
performance through working with us
through that entire process
and so for the last part of of this
presentation and I really do appreciate
all of your time today uh we are going
to talk about the how we ultimately
increase protein yields through the
actual expression uh and uh purification
processes that we offer within Thermo
Fisher Gene art as I mentioned it you
know there's a lot of advantages to
using the xb293 and XP Joe mammalian
systems that really Express more protein
per cell that's what everyone's trying
to get to how can I get the highest
yield for uh you know the the in the
fastest amount of time for the lowest
amount of cost using these expression
systems is a great way to do that and in
our case you can see in that first Red
Box there uh using these expression
systems will allow you to have a higher
cells density meaning on a per cell
basis you're going to have higher uh
productivity and a higher efficiency
transaction as well and you can see that
the protocol is very easy it plugs right
into the five to seven day workflow that
usually uh goes on when it comes to
using the expression systems but what I
want to highlight is when paired with
our Gene and Vector optimization as I
mentioned
more often than not we are seeing a 3 to
10x yield Improvement by combining all
of these factors and so you may in
certain cases see those benefits on the
right or on the left but they are
enhanced when you combine them with that
Gene optimization that I that that I
mentioned earlier and it's more reliable
and results in a higher yield than you
would otherwise get with without doing
the gene optimization
and as I mentioned I really encourage
you to take a look at those as I
highlighted earlier
earlier just a
clinician in terms of the gibco protein
expression systems their their industry
leading it's likely many of the
participants of this call are very
familiar with them uh in terms of
antibody screening immunogen production
membrane and intracellular protein
expression uh on the left you're going
to see heck 293 the cell based system
that can have a protein yield up to one
gram per liter
in terms of yield and on the right XB
Cho you know really as far as show cells
are concerned another industry-leading
cell based system you're going to be
getting protein yields up to three grams
per liter which in the bioproduction
community really is uh toward the upper
limit of capability especially if you're
getting them on a consistent basis like
you would be uh within working with the
gene art framework a lot of the
applications for Cho are some of those
more advanced newer applications like
buy specifics other multi-specifics
um and then of course antibodies are
really uh you know monoclonal antibodies
with Cho cells uh those those are really
popularized workflows that I'm sure many
of you on the call are well aware of and
experienced with today
and just to highlight a bit about the XD
show uh system in terms of the
expression levels uh you know the
tighter in terms of grams per liter you
can see the comparison versus uh the
freestyle show which is a which is
another show system the xp293 and then
ultimately the xdho system and you'll
see just a massive increase in terms of
expression levels
um comparatively with this XP Trio
system and so it's definitely worth uh
using we love it in-house at Gene art we
do recommend it for a lot of our
mammalian protein expression projects
and we're uh very interested in helping
to identify exactly why this particular
cell uh expression system is it might be
best for your sequence but again one of
the benefits of working with GNR is with
all that experience we can do the exact
opposite we can also tell you when not
to use it and when there may be a better
alternative
um as well but more often than not this
XP chair system we're we're very very uh
big fans of we highly recommend it and
that's something that we're really
um really happy to be able to use
in-house within the Thermo Fisher
family of companies
okay
so moving on to the final Parts in the r
d uh scale bio production you know
you're going to be interested in
purification and Analysis ultimately we
have a number of ways that we can do
purification
um we do a lot of them as you can see in
inside that cell
um we're inside that box there
um we're we're very experienced in this
and we feel very comfortable with it and
in terms of our analysis we have a
number of ways some of our standard
processes are the SDS page Nano drop
capillary gel electrophoresis but we can
do some other uh approaches as well on
hplc when it comes to size exclusion
chromatography also we can and have done
with a lot of our partners and detox and
detection
um that is a process that we do get
requested a lot and it's very important
in particular when you're dealing with
for example in certain cases toxic
sequences which can sometimes happen but
are significantly lower risk when you're
starting with that Gene optimization
process that I mentioned earlier
so just talking a bit about our uh Gene
protein Services the purification
approaches you can see everything in the
box there um you know we've got a number
of different chromatography approaches
that you can take to purification we
also have different types of affinity
tags but we also do provide unique
customization options which is uh pretty
unique I would say to a provider like
Therma Fisher who does do a lot of
proteins oftentimes on a high throughput
basis we will do everything from
concentration adjustments all the way to
things that aren't listed here
um like choosing custom tubes for
example you let us know what your needs
are and we will do our best to
absolutely help you toward making your
project go as smoothly as possible and
as quickly as possible
um and as I mentioned you know we have a
lot of different ways uh the filtration
and purification approaches that we have
are not just one one size fits all
um so to speak we understand that every
uh project is unique and I would go so
far as to say we understand it better
because a lot of times our partners
start at that Gene optimization level so
we can see it coming in our production
Pipeline and really understand when we
may or may not run into purification
challenges so that's another benefit of
working
um for your entire production workflow
at this early Discovery stage with our
our Gene art services
here's an example uh and this is my
second to last slide here of some of the
documentation that you might receive uh
early on working with our Gene art
Services here we will provide a
certificate of analysis results of the
chromatography for example we really
want to make sure that you have a lot of
confidence uh in in trusting us as you
are outsourced provider for transient
protein expression for those early
services that you might be looking at
you know it's one thing to be able to do
it in-house and feel like you have
control over every step of the process
but we understand that for some people
on this call that can be cost
prohibitive from an equipment
perspective or an investment perspective
and so we want to make working with Gene
art really feel like an extension of
your laboratory we want it to be
personalized to you so that we build
that trust over time time and really can
grow with you we want to help scale with
you uh we you know value every single
one of our customers it's not that we
will just push your proteins through as
quickly as possible we want to treat
every single customer that comes to us
with the uh respect that we would have
doing all of our projects with our own r
d teams and our manufacturing team with
all of their experience they they truly
have seen it all and I can tell you that
we're very proud to talk about how our
team cares so much each and every day
about the projects that they work on
and finally
I'd like to just share a little bit of
information about uh upcoming services
and we actually do provide this on a
pilot basis right now the highest
throughput XP show expression and
purification Service uh in as fast as 21
days you can go from sequence
all the way through purified protein
with that analytical report in either 24
or 96 well played that's really great
for antibody uh screening uh that's
something that we have a lot of Partners
a lot of the a lot of the bigger
partners that you are probably very
familiar with like this service because
it allows them to explore a number of
targets all at once before ultimately
scaling up uh to higher scales or
production volumes and so you know you
can save a lot of time a lot of money we
understand things are getting smaller uh
we understand that needs are getting
faster but maintaining the higher uh
quality product that you're used to and
we can say that as we scale down we are
not sacrificing quality in by any means
and this is one new product offering
that we're very excited to have and
offer you today
we now ask that you participate by
answering these poll questions our first
poll question is would you like to
receive a quote for an early stage
protein production project
remember to record your answer click on
your selection
again would you like to receive a quote
for an early stage protein production
project
we'll move to our next poll question
would you like to be contacted by a
technical sales specialist to understand
more about our protein services
please select yes or no
you record your selection by clicking on
the answer
would you like to be contacted by a
technical sales specialist to understand
more about our protein services
and then our final poll question
if you have a de novo Gene synthesis
project currently in process either
in-house or outsourced to a provider
when do you anticipate you'll require
protein Production Services
one to three months
two to six months
or six plus months
click on the answer
record your selection
if you have a de novo Gene synthesis
project currently in process either
in-house or outsourced to a provider
when do you anticipate you'll require
protein Production Services
one to three months
two to six months
or six plus months
that'll give you a few more seconds to
record your answer
thank you for participating in the poll
questions we will now be hearing from Dr
Jeff Howe representing the Pharma
Services Group within Thermo Fisher
Scientific
one of the goals today and the reason
for doing this some webinar is to
explain how you can go from the r d
environment to commercial scale
production
at Gene art they are proud to take on
the earliest stages of your research
even when you are not sure what is going
to happen all the way to the point when
you feel comfortable moving to Mouse
studies and ultimately clinical trials
by working with Thermo Fisher Scientific
you get the benefit of that early stage
transient protein expression the
discovery services and then how to move
quickly into clinic and ultimately to
commercial scale production in one
seamless integrated way within the
Thermo Fisher framework
Jeff you may now begin your presentation
I appreciate the introduction there so
so I hope everyone's doing well and uh
let's kind of move on uh from the the r
d in into the production of the bio
production side
just want to refocus
um the the audience here a little bit uh
as Steve kind of presented uh going from
concept to commercialization uh it is
quite a big Endeavor and and we I just
want to try to break this down
um a little bit further on the next
slide As you move
um out of Discovery and into development
and in subsequent stages
um so so Therma Fisher Scientific will
continue to be your partner As you move
out of that phase and it's really
important that we overcome uh or once
you've overcome some of those
development hurdles as presented by
Steve uh we we have uh you know the
offerings that that are necessary to get
you through the next stages now for the
rest of this uh presentation I'll focus
on the development section I will refer
to to some of the the clinical and
Commercial aspects while focus on on
some of the development and elements uh
in in the rest of the slide deck
so really the key is to really leverage
the experience of a partner that can
offer a really mature platform
uh which is built that allows for easy
transition into predictable supply chain
so that you are getting the product uh
if and when you need it
um so so this development process uh
these solutions that we're looking for
uh to create this new therapeutic is
really critical
um first step in moving into some of the
clinical trials and commercial
production
so our capabilities
um
truly demonstrate an end-to-end service
offering from DNA to patient and and
that's really bounded by you know the
foundations of quality
um so if I was to kind of now focus in a
little bit on the process development
optimate optimization side once you come
out of that Discovery uh piece uh we're
really focused on uh the process
development elements of your of your
molecule
so that includes things like cell on
development cell culture customization
there could be certain analytical
aspects that that we want to look at
whether it's related to characterization
or some post-translational modifications
or it could be to do with scale up or
Tech transfer and in-process monitoring
as well as uh finally you know
generating some material whether that's
it's for that top study or reference
standard and these are really important
factors as we now embark on this journey
of Bio production and move into both
your clinical trials and and hopefully
uh into that commercial launch at therm
official scientific uh specifically
within the Pharma Services
we have these world-class product
capabilities to to Really drive you
there
these capabilities are definitely
industry leading um and
um and and what I mean by that
um is that we have been extremely
patient-centric in in delivering over
160 molecules
um over 20 years of manufacturing
experience uh really compressed into
some of the capabilities and service
offerings that that we have to offer uh
to you as our customers and and
ultimately to our patients
um it's truly end-to-end from
development to manufacturing
um for both DS NDP as you can see on on
this right hand side moving from both
material packaging distribution and
ultimately logistics for both clinical
and Commercial and that has really uh
paved the way uh for a lot of success
for some of the molecules that we have
developed for our customers
so you're not alone when it comes to
evolving the r d pipelines on biologics
here we see some Market projections as
well as
how we've got into this point
uh with with a keger of 11.4 right this
pipeline you know continues to be
extremely strong
um even during covert times
now while there there is a wild uh wide
diversity of molecule types
um almost 40 in that pre pre-clinical
phase revolves around monoclonal
antibodies um and that's definitely one
area that I want to try to help uh
Target today it is around these
monoclonal antibodies
um when we discuss development the
monoclonal antibodies certainly provide
some baseline on on timeline and speed
but with changes in molecular complexity
as you can see here on the right hand
side whether it's things like adcs or
Fusion proteins by specific antibodies
we can use that platform that we've
developed from monoclonal antibodies as
a basis to further evolve the Scopes so
that we can explore greater design
spaces
as a way to de-risk your CMC activity so
so even though this presentation will
focus uh specifically on the the
development and and mad side of things I
think that other 60 we can certainly
tackle with you as well uh based on
again the capabilities and and
experience that we have gathered uh
throughout our 20 years of experience
all right so so then
now that so so let me pull you back to
um to what we have discussed so far
which is now that you've started your
engines on on Discovery and and working
with Gina to generate those first pieces
of asset on the construct and and on the
molecule specifically your next
challenges will likely be uh on that
that first and human you know how
quickly can you get into first and human
um and the speed into the clinic as well
as deliver delivering a robust and and
uh productive process into manufacturing
so so as you move along this path as you
get into clinical and Commercial uh
there's a certain demand that that is
required and and certainly ensuring that
you have a process to meet those demands
is going to be critical
this now puts the spotlight on on things
like selling development process
development and potentially that scale
Up pilot scale uh as as uh paths that
will now fall on the critical timeline
if you're thinking about speed to Clinic
all right so then
speak can be formulated in a number of
ways at therm official scientific our
service offerings are are being
modernized with the latest technology
and automation
throughout the various functions of
development we have invested in
advancements in developing new
technology and automation that will take
take us there faster so for example if
we we look at you know some of the
Automation and latest technologies that
we have invested in we start with Salon
development a really targeted approach
uh utilizing microfluidics and oep
technology for single cell cloning
moving into some of the process side
where we have the Amber 15 as well as
tcam robotics to really facilitate that
both to facilitate both the Upstream
Downstream process development at the
smaller scale
and then that the process is in and the
cell line I should say is complemented
uh by analytical and characterization
foundations through the multi-attribute
method and and that's using workflow
that leverages uh lcms methodology to
obtain uh product quality attributes
such as glycans and charge variant data
to now really shine a light on on
product quality As you move into
bioproduction
if I was to kind of take one example
um let's focus back on uh the the beacon
platform
as mentioned that the beacon platform is
a is a microfluidic system that uses oep
technology so opto electronic
positioning
um and it uses light to help us with
single cell cloning uh single cell
cleaning traditionally is done through
limiting dilution but with the beacon
we're able to now uh use
um now able to seed cells into a
microfluidic device and then sort the
cells uh based on monoclonality
uh if you look at the schematic on on
the bottom uh the the instrument is on
the left with the image in the middle
showing how we're using oep to channel
cells uh into uh what's what's called
these Nano pins so it's like channels
within the microfluidic device and then
we're able to assess both growth and
productivity uh over a a five-day period
but so this has introduced
um significant amount of automation as
well as modernization to the to the way
we we deal with cell line development
into the way we introduce a cell line uh
into the bio production pathway
so realizing speed to IND or impd
is not just accelerating uh the the
platform
um the quick the clinic offering is uh
is our offering to which uh has gone
through careful uh construction and
integration of a number of things
certainly the first one is around the
workflows uh it's it's around the beacon
it's around the Amber systems and the
miniaturization that we're able to to
get out of that workflows as well as the
analytical methods um so so as we
developed the the molecule and the
process that there's understanding of
the process that's required through
various analytical methods
but I think you know what's more
important is the robustness of that
platform uh with over 80 PD programs
since 2017
um and now I revamped uh XP chose Choice
cell line which I'll I'll talk into I'll
speak to a little bit more detail in
subsequent slides is really getting us
to to the productivity that that we're
looking for and then also leveraging the
process development experience that
we've had through those programs and
this is then combined with assessing
risk and you'll hear me talk about risk
throughout this presentation uh which is
really critical as as we uh we're
thinking about uh moving to that r d or
impd
but so we talk about timelines we talk
about
um accelerating we talk about speed so
this is our quick to Clinic 2.0 timeline
it's accelerated and optimized start to
finish workflow that as you can see
draws on a number of parallel activities
we have taken a really careful approach
to to identifying what's on the critical
timeline and then optimizing the
workflow accordingly and this is the end
product of that approach you can see
that some assumptions are made through
the workflow but what's truly impressive
is that this is not just completing a
GMP batch um at the end it's integrating
the PD to the tech transfer as well as
the GMP operations and finally we're
able to release your dsmdp within that
time frame and this is all because we
are with you every step of the way to
really get you closer to that IND or
impd submission
so so moving along then having seen the
the timeline I'm sure by now you're
wondering how we addressing some of the
risks um and the with the amount of
concurrent work
uh mitigating predictable risk is
certainly embedded in in this offering
in the quick to clean uh offering
um and you know there are three key
pieces
um our approach is really leveraging a
well characterized cell line uh which is
coming up next
um that will help reduce inherent risks
uh and failure points as we move from
Discovery to bioproduction
um and then it's it's about advancing
our platforms so we have invested
um heavily in into developing this
platform uh that really is able to to
pull together the the critical pieces
that you need in getting you to that IND
so then quick to clean 2.0
um has definitely been focused
um on a revamped cell line um and that
being the gibco freedom XP Choice line
so Steve had mentioned you know some of
the work uh that uh has been done uh
through his group
um and and more importantly uh the the
heck 293 cell line as well the XP Cho
being really uh critical foundations
um in the r d uh environment in in
generating some of these products and
now we've really turned uh the transient
system uh into stable one certainly for
our workflow at the very beginning where
we're doing cloning and Gene synthesis
um in some of the plasma prep work that
is supported throughout our Gene art
entity
um and and really this is uh our
transition point where we're going from
Discovery uh into by production what's
also really critical here is that
anything that you learn through
Discovery is maintained right whether
it's through Vector design or other
things and that those are all maintained
as we transition to bio production we
don't want to lose any
um of the really critical aspects that
you put into the design of your
construct through this initial process
so so this is really the handshake that
you see uh going from Gene art into the
farm services
so when we think about the freedom Expos
sell line
um it's the same robust cell line uh but
there's only GMP banked uh that that
you've used uh through the transient
system uh has been adapted for high
density culture
um getting to two by seven uh to to
around two by seven
um or two by ten to the seven cells per
mil it's been documented in literature
of its uh rapid doubling times
um as well as the the ability to to be
to produce
a high amount of protein as you can see
uh on your right hand side uh definitely
in the grams range
between that that three to four range
oh and then when we think about uh the
cell line and the stability of the cell
line uh we've seen good stability across
many of the Clones that we've generated
uh whether it's for mab or recombinant
protein and certainly we've seen really
high quality and and very active protein
uh where where we're looking through
some of the analytical methods
um so so so if if you take one message
away from this slide it's to say that
the the cell line the host cell lines
that you're using for the transient
um your transient operations will be the
same cell line that you use for your
Stables
now consistent quality between transient
stable clones is really critical
um and and I think that as Steve had
mentioned uh certainly for the xpros
system uh in the transient format we've
seen gram ranges as demonstrated on the
left hand side we've also seen very
comparable product quality here you see
some in glycan data moving from
transients to Stables uh with the 400
times increase in scale as well
um and certainly while we see some
differences The gcrf Still Remains
relatively consistent throughout
and the final piece to the freedom Expos
is the the regulatory support
information
um there is a a master file uh for this
particular cell line uh in the form of a
document
um a regulatory package that provides uh
the uh the information around the cell
line the history the lineage as well as
characterization
there is uh certainly application data
package that's available
um and then
um the the lineage as mentioned
um in supporting your regulatory filing
so just a couple of slides left
um now going through the and introducing
to you the the stable system the stable
XP Choice system and how it fits within
quick to Clinique
2.0 we've really laid the foundations uh
for success for your IND or impd
so hopefully you know you can see that
quick to Clinic
um is uh formulating the the pieces that
are really critical for this Foundation
um where it combines the process the
analytics as well as the scale-up
strategy uh with a really robust cell
line
um that is available now to create your
molecule interest
um you know it's only through
um
through some of the slides you could see
that it's been integrated into our
platform uh it continues to be royalty
free or exit fee free
um and and we we have a uh a significant
body of data around scale-up Solutions
uh well beyond your IND and impd
Milestones
kind of some some my section up
um
quick to Clinic is just that first step
um in in really getting your molecule
uh past the the IND and impd is is that
first step in the Life uh the the drug
life cycle
um I want to highlight here that
certainly Pharma Services is able to
help you go beyond that
um going from both lab to clinic and
then to commercial so so we have some
additional Services which
um I'm sure that there will be
opportunities in the future to kind of
share with you
um so let me sum it up
um and I'll try to sum up stay section
as well if I can
um so so as Steve presented
um you know partnering with Therma
Fisher Scientific and significantly
speed up your development timelines
starting with Gene synthesis is the
fastest way um to screen uh and uh
um to screen those clones to identify
the candidates that's necessary for for
that next step of borrow production GNR
services at through what Steve had
presented uh can accelerate the protein
r d timelines and really simplify your
process
um and I think ultimately what I took
out of uh what Steve had said is is
really help you come up with a solution
um in in addressing you know some of the
challenges as you go through that kind
of workflow
now while the speaker Clinic is one of
the most critical goals coming out of
Discovery
um it shouldn't be prioritized at the
expense of other critical success
factors and I hope that uh you know that
risk-based assessment that you saw
throughout the presentation
um helps uh to to
um to address that point
and then work with with things like
Therma Fisher Scientific who can offer
seamless scale up Solutions beyond the
IND and impd Milestone
um certainly this is uh this is really
critical and uh we we should kind of
ensure that uh that there is complete
end to end for any molecule or any drug
that you're trying to funnel through
that life cycle approach
and finally a quick to Clinic program
for monoclonal antibodies that's
designed to take you from transfection
to r d in as little as 13 months it's
certainly Market leading
um and you know we balance uh the risks
um to the reward as well
but with that
um I'll move over to that final slide
just some contact information or any um
any additional information that you need
please uh reach out
um and uh with that I want to thank you
for for your attendance uh to this
webinar
thank you Steve and Jeff
performative presentation we will now
start the Q a portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is for Steve
can we ship clones from another provider
for Gene art to perform protein
expression and purification projects
that's a great question uh the answer is
yes you absolutely can do that one of
the things that we do encourage within
uh Gene art services at Therma Fisher
Scientific is the fact that we can do
the entire Continuum from DNA sequence
all the way through Express uh and
purifying protein in-house so you will
get a higher level of service and likely
a higher level of quality as well by
working with us at Thermo Fisher Gene
art from the very beginning and one
thing that we can do as a result of
doing that is at any point in the
process you have the ability to have
better control over everything sometimes
there's a risk in shipping clones and
that there can be
um you know mislabeled tubes there can
be uh shipping conditions or packaging
that are not up to par that we don't
have any control over if we receive it
in that way and if the reason for
wanting to do that revolves around
pricing we're more than happy to discuss
options to really provide you everything
that you need in-house from that
sequence design all the way through the
purified protein so feel free to contact
one of your Therma Fisher Partners who
you work with and we'd be more more than
happy to discuss the different options
available to you
thank you and it looks like we have time
for one more question this question is
for Jeff
how are you addressing current
challenges around raw material sourcing
with regards to the quick to Clinic
solution
thanks Marie
um yeah no doubt this one's on
everyone's mind it's certainly a
challenging environment right now
that said with this kind of platform
approach that we're taking there's only
a standard set of single-use components
and a standard set of resins and media
that that we we would use and we're able
to really procure those uh well in
advance in preparation for the GMP
manufacturing batch
um and and sometimes even uh before uh
prior to to that signature so so really
it depends on uh where where we are in
terms of you know the just
um the discussions with uh contractual
items and things like that but but you
know that there's always you know with
with such a uh changing environment
there's always opportunities uh to to go
through and and identify the the
critical uh timeline items that that's
stopping us uh from from moving forward
so and then we're always open for that
discussion so
um so so that will be my answer to that
Marie thank you
thank you Steve and Jeff for your time
today and your important research before
we go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
I'd also like to thank our sponsors
Thermo Fisher Scientific for sponsoring
today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until April 21st 2024.
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye